welcome back we're doing Part B and Part
A problem number two and it says use a
trapezoidal sum with three sub intervals
to estimate the average number of people
waiting in line during the first four
hours and so I just took the data they
gave graphed it I did that in the last
video and so what you know use
trapezoidal sum with three sub intervals
to estimate the average number of people
that sounds very complicated like boy I
don't that sounds yeah you know I didn't
learn trapezoidal psalms or however you
want to think about it it could be very
confusing and frankly I haven't taken
calculus in 20 years but you really just
have to think about what they're saying
it's not that daunting so what's the
average value of a function and you
learned this in calculus you might not
remember it the average value so let's
say the average value of F is equal to
essentially the let's say between two
points bo na it's the difference between
the two points divided by the area under
the curve of f of X from A to B right
that's I think if they call that the
second fundamental theorem of calculus
or corollary to the fundamental theorem
of calculus whatever but it makes sense
right the average value of a function is
equal to the area under the curve
divided by you could kind of say the
base of the figure right because another
way to think about it if you just took
the average value of the function so if
the function was say this this was let's
say the average function value of the
function was this and you just
multiplied that average value times the
base you would get the same area as the
integral that's another way to view it
you could rewrite this as B minus a the
base times the average value is the same
thing as the area under the curve DX so
that's another way to view it so let's
just apply that here let's fit use the
trapezoidal sum to figure out the area
under this curve or an estimate of the
area under L of T and then we can divide
by B minus a or in that case B is 4 a is
0 and we'll have the average value of
over the first 4 hours of the people in
line so let's do that
let me erase it we're actually not going
to use an integral we're going to use a
trapezoidal sum to estimate the integral
so it says three intervals it says a
trapezoidal to sum with three sub
intervals well I see there's three very
natural sub intervals here and let me
draw them so this is one right actually
let me
well I'll draw the dotted lines this is
one sub interval this is another sub
interval and there we have we have three
trapezoids we have this one we have this
one and we have this trapezoid so we
essentially just have to figure out the
area of each of these trapezoids let me
see if I can draw that a little bit I'll
draw them in different colors as you can
see the trapezoids
so this trapezoid goes from I don't know
if I'm doing this right let's see I use
a line tool so if one trapezoid here and
then another trapezoid there and then
another trapezoid there I just need to
figure out the areas of each of these
trapezoids and that's my estimate of the
area under the curve of L of T from 0 to
4 and then I've just divided by 4 and
I'm done
Part B so what's the area of this first
trapezoid well what do you do to find an
area of the trapezoid it's the base so
this area of this trapezoid right here
this first one is the base which is just
one one times the average of the two
Heights right so it's the average this
is right here it's 120 and this is 156
so what's the average of 120 and 156
well the average of 120 and 156 let's
see that we get 276 divided by 2 is 138
so it's 1 times 138 or it's just 138
that's the area of that trapezoid what's
the area of this trapezoid right here
this bigger one
well its base is 2 right 1 2 its bases -
and what's the average value well it's
going to be the average value between
156 and 176 or the average value between
this height and this height
that's an easier one right 166 is right
in between those two we don't have to do
much that's 2 times 166 sorry 1 166 not
1.6 6 and then finally what's the
average value of this trap or what's
what's the area in this of this
trapezoid well the base is 1 Ryan just
going from 3 to 4 1 times the average
value so 176 and 126 so that is one-half
times
what's 176 let me use a calculator just
so I don't make any mistakes trusty
ti-85 emulator so let's see 176 plus 126
enter divided by 2 is equal to 151 so
this area right here it's 1 times 1 51
or 151 so what's the total area that's
just going to be the sum of these three
trapezoids so it's the sum of those
three trapezoids it's going to be 138
plus 2 times
166 plus 151 so that's the total area
under those trapezoids but then they ask
us well let's see what's the average
value of the function well the average
value is just the area divided by the
base the base is formed right from noon
to 4:00 p.m. or from zero time equals
zero at a time equals four so we just
divide this value by 4 so divided by
four we get 155 point two five so they
say use a trapezoidal sum with three sub
intervals to estimate the average number
of people waiting in line during the
first four hours that the tickets were
on sale so the answer to Part B is 155
0.25 they don't tell us to round it or
anything so I'm assuming that's you know
if we're saying the average number of
people I guess we can have a fraction
there so that's reasonable part let's
see what part of you we're on Part C
okay so Part C I think that's going to
use this graph to so let me erase at
least this
top part the top part I can erase I can
erase this I can erase that I want to
erase all the unnecessary things let me
see if I can see I could erase all of
that just want to make it as neat as
possible I think the scrap is going to
come in useful in part see if I just
glancing at it okay that's good enough I
think okay let's do Part C let me let me
copy and paste it C Part C okay copied
it edit paste okay 40 is greater than
zero is less than nine right what is the
fewest number of times at which l prime
of T must be equal to zero
give a reason for your answer so L prime
of T that's the derivative of this this
is these you know what I when I
connected these dots I just kind of
wanted to get a shape of the curve but
it's really a curve it's not like this
sharp edged line right and how do we
know it's a curve because it's
differentiable it's continuous it's
actually twice differentiable which
tells us the derivative is continuous so
the real graph of this is going to look
something you know let me do it in a
bold color like magenta you know it
might look something like this I don't
know a curve and then it it maxes out at
some point comes down then it comes up
like this and then it maybe it maxes out
and it comes down like that it'll be a
curve right well anyway they say what is
the fewest number of times that L prime
of T must be equal to zero
well what happens when L prime of T is
equal to zero that means that we are at
a local minima or a local Maxima or
sometimes an inflection point but we
don't we don't know that for sure but at
minima and maximum point we know for
sure that L prime of T is equal to zero
and so we could just eyeball we could
look at this graph and we could say well
you know there has to be a minimum point
someplace in this range right between
here and
year so you know for the way I drew it
there's it looks like the slope is zero
there and between here and here it looks
like the slope is also going to have to
bottom out at some point like there and
then there's a maximum point right
someplace in this range and it's going
to max out so when I just eyeball it I
say well I have two maximal points and
one minimum point so the slope is going
to equal zero at at least three points
right but they tell us give us a reason
for your answer give us a reason and my
reason and you could use you know you
could try to use and actually you could
use rolls theorem or the mean value
theorem but the simplest reason is that
here we have a we have three sign
changes in the average velocity or the
average not the average velocity the
rate the the L of T we're not doing
velocity in this problem so from here we
use a thicker line use yellow so from
here to here we have a sign change from
here to here we have a sign change from
here to here we could have a sign change
so what I would write down at the AP
exam is I was like well the function is
is twice differentiable which means its
derivative is continuous so let me write
down the important points so derivative
is continuous derivative is continuous
and we have three sign changes in the
derivative right the derivative is
positive over this interval at least the
its its average is positive that it goes
negative so at some point since the
derivative is continuous it doesn't jump
around it had to be positive someplace
in this range and you could be more
formal when you write it had to be
negative someplace in this range so
there had to be a sign change and so it
had to pass through zero and that same
argument could be used between here and
here and here and here and that's my
answer and I will continue Part D in the
next video because I'm already over ten
minutes